[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend wir sind live
mit zdf heute live seit heute nachmittag
16 uhr beraten sich die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder mit
kanzler scholz es geht um die
verschärfung der korona maßnahmen wegen
der omicron variante die sich rasant
ausbreite zurzeit das können wir in
anderen ländern wie großbritannien sehen
das beratende gremium der
bundesregierung der expertenrat hat ja
gestern schärfere maßnahmen gefordert
jetzt warten wir also auf die ergebnisse
der bund länder runde die
pressekonferenz soll heute noch
stattfinden und wir sehen im moment
sitzt noch keiner am tisch also können
wir noch weiter sprechen was ist los
gehts ja das hängt davon ab wie schnell
sich die teilnehmenden einig werden das
haben wir in den letzten fast zwei
jahren gelernt das kann dauern kann aber
auch schnell gehen wir haben gehört es
gibt gerüchte dass es so in ungefähr 20
minuten losgehen soll wir sprechen heute
abend mit professor thorsten leer als
modell ihrer beobachtet er wie sich die
infektionswellen entwickeln wir sprechen
mit dem monologen professor karsten
watzl und wir schon gleich nach hamburg
wo jetzt schon zu den feiertagen
strengere regeln gelten werden und wir
schalten natürlich live nach berlin dann
wenn die pressekonferenz beginnt also
sie können gerne bei uns bleiben bei uns
verpassen sie nichts und schicken sie
uns ihre fragen und ihre kommentare an
die adresse die sie jetzt unten
eingeblendet sehen oder schreiben sie
alles in die kommentarspalten also wir
legen gleich los wir haben die
pressekonferenz im blick und sind sofort
dabei wenn es losgeht vorher bringt uns
ines trump nochmal auf den aktuellen
stand der dinge
das krisentreffen kurzfristig einberufen
wegen der sich rasant ausbreitenden
omikron variante kontakt beschränkungen
planen bund und länder so hört man vorab
allerdings erst ab ende dezember an
weihnachten will man nicht dran nur
stunden vor dem treffen prescht das lka
mit einem strategiepapier vor es fordert
sofort zusammenkünfte drinnen bis zehn
personen zu erlauben eine generelle
masken pflicht ab zwei personen
großveranstaltungen zu verbieten und
bars discos und auch restaurants zu
schließen verteidigung einer der
ministerpräsidentinnen die an der video
schalte mit dem kanzler teilnimmt
experten der bundesregierung und der
besteht aus 19 wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen und das rk ii ist
ein teil davon hatten eine einstimmige
empfehlung abgegeben und an dieser
empfehlungen orientieren wir uns in
unserem beschluss csu-chef söder zeigt
sich höchst irritiert ob der
vielstimmigkeit wann sollen die
einschränkungen nun greifen der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat noch am
sonntag dies für weihnachten
ausgeschlossen dass ihm unterstellt sie
institut des lka sagt das gegenteil
also das muss halt nochmal aufgeklärt
und was ist jetzt die aussage auch
hamburg macht sein eigenes ding und
damit druck auf das bund länder treffen
der stadtstaat selbst bereits früher
bereits ab weihnachten schärfere kontakt
beschränkungen ein weil wir die
erfahrung gemacht haben in der pandemie
wenn wir wissen dass maßnahmen
erforderlich sind das ist dann besser
ist sie sofort zu ergreifen und besser
früher als später in kraft zu setzen
kontakt beschränkungen auch geister
stadien geschlossene clubs und bars all
das wird kommen wann ist allerdings
offen kommen die einschränkungen zum
heiligen abend oder erst zu silvester
bund und länder ringen zur stunde um die
richtige antwort
also hamburg macht sein eigenes ding das
haben wir gerade gehört und deshalb
sprechen wir jetzt dort mit unserem
korrespondenten ralf zimmermann von
seefahrt reif schönen guten abend
ich
vielleicht zunächst mal was ist denn
jetzt genau bei euch beschlossen in
hamburg was kommt
im grunde ist es ganz simpel also
erstens ist beschlossen dass die
maßnahmen zum 24 in kraft treten also
das hat er
hamburgs erster bürgermeister heute in
einer landespressekonferenz heute mittag
schon verkündet bis zu zehn personen
dürfen sich privat treffen wenn sie alle
geimpft sind sobald ein ungeimpfter
dabei ist dürfen es nur drei personen
seien aber bis zu zehn personen bei
privaten zusammenkünften sämtliche
diskus amtliche tanzveranstaltungen wie
das wörtlich hieß werden nicht mehr
erlaubt sein und man wird auch eine
sperrstunde wieder einführen nämlich um
23 uhr bis auf den silvestertag wird
diese sperrstunde also auch dann ab
samstag sofort gelten also das sind die
scharfen maßnahmen die hamburg jetzt
vorsieht und damit ist tschentscher
heute mittag schon mal vorgeprescht mit
dem was jetzt in berlin gerade
verhandelt wird da stellt sich natürlich
die frage warum macht er das warum zieht
er die massnahmen vor
na ja er ist eben der er ist eher der
eindeutigen überzeugung dass man
frühzeitig maßnahmen von denen man
überzeugt ist und er ist es auf jeden
fall und viele andere im politischen
raum ja auch und auch in der bevölkerung
dass man das frühzeitig machen soll dass
man das dann machen sollte wenn
tatsächlich man der überzeugung ist dass
es nötig ist sodann nicht warten sollte
er hat das hat den schwarzen peter jetzt
nicht schon irgendwelchen anderen
politischen playern der
ministerpräsidenten oder gar der ampel
koalition zugeschoben aber es ist ganz
klar zu erkennen dass tschentscher das
als dringende maßnahme sieht und deshalb
auch ein klares signal setzen wollte
denn im grunde ist natürlich dieser
zeitpunkt jetzt willkürlich gewählt aber
eben der dienstag nach der senatssitzung
hier in hamburg also spielen sich ja
auch interne gründe eine rolle warum man
das dann so schön verkaufen kann die
klarheit von tschentscher ist ja
allgemein bekannt und die legt er jetzt
wieder an den tag mit dieser mit diesen
maßnahmen die jetzt beschlossen wurden
wir erinnern uns ja auch älter war ja
auch nicht unbedingt dafür dass die
epidemische lage auslaufen soll das war
ja auch nicht ganz unproblematisch weil
seine partei die spd dass er maßgeblich
mit auf den weg gebracht hat
ja genau und er hat heute das auch noch
einmal in dieser landespressekonferenz
betont dass er ja von vornherein gesagt
habe man solle die epidemische notlage
nationaler tragweite doch bis
weihnachten zumindest gelten lassen das
hat er auch tatsächlich gesagt aber er
hat sehr leise gesagt und das hatte
natürlich schon was mit der ampel zu tun
und der regierungsbildung in berlin
tschentscher das merkt man ihm schon an
ist ja sozusagen von olaf scholz hier in
hamburg
also er hat olaf scholz hier
ist ihm nach gefolgt und insofern ist
natürlich die verbindung nach berlin zur
zu scholz ins kanzleramt jetzt mit allen
leuten auch den hamburger lloyd mit
denen schätzungen geben ist sehr eng
also da vieles tschentscher schon ein
bisschen schwer dann zu deutlich zu
werden aber mit der heutigen mit der
heute mit den heutigen maßnahmen hat er
darin punkt gesetzt und ich glaube
letztlich wird er das jetzt auch tun
weil er ist ja mediziner ist bekannt
dafür gewesen während der ganzen
pandemie dass er sehr scharfe und
deutliche maßnahmen immer ergriffen hat
wenn es nötig war und ist damit ja
insgesamt in hamburg ganz gut gefahren
auch wenn man sagen muss die inzidenz
ist so hoch heute in hamburg so hoch wie
sie noch nie war mit
348 punkte glaube ich sind das heute 348
er incident an einem tag fast um 40
punkte gestiegen von gestern auf heute
also in hamburg gibt es ein ganz
heftiges virulentes geschehen und man
muss jetzt mal abwarten wie sich die
lage hier entwickelt ob das was der
hamburger senat was fans jetzt hier
verkündet hat und die maßnahmen die
ergriffen hat ob die genügen
wir warten auf die pressekonferenz die
jetzt in diesen minuten los geht vielen
dank für den moment ich sehe gerade wie
bundeskanzler scholz die bühne betritt
bzw an den tisch tritt und ja wir gehen
jetzt auf die pressekonferenz und hören
welche maßnahmen beschlossen werden
mir macht der mai
meine damen meine herren ich darf sie
herzlich begrüßen zur pressekonferenz im
anschluss an die ich sag mal
voraussichtlich letzte
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz des jahres
ich darf begrüßen wo das kanzler olaf
scholz den nordrhein westfälischen
ministerpräsidenten hendrik wüst und die
frischgebackene berliner regierende
bürgermeisterin franziska gefallen
erfolg hängt an
meine damen und herren heute hat sich
die bundesregierung mit den
ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten der 16 länder
getroffen bevor ich aber zu den inhalten
unseres treffens kommen mehr möchte ich
heute der neu gewählten regierenden
bürgermeisterin von berlin franziska
giffey einen herzlichen glückwunsch sein
wie ist die zeitläufe wollen ist sie nun
gleich am tag ihrer wahl als co
vorsitzender der konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten gefordert gewesen
daher freue ich mich dass sie nun mit
herrn wüst und mir zusammen über die
heutigen beratung berichten kann
ziel unserer unter regung unterredung
mit den ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten war ist unser land
auf die bevorstehende nächste corona
welle vorzubereiten
bin froh dass der von uns eingesetzte
expertenrat am wochenende eine so klare
und im übrigen einhellige einschätzung
zu omikron abgegeben hat ich danke an
dieser stelle den wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern und all den übrigen
experten für diese wichtige arbeit
ihre wissenschaftliche einschätzung ist
die grundlage für die politischen
entscheidungen die wir jetzt treffen
und ich bin dankbar dass wir so zügig im
kreis der 16 länder und der
bundesregierung zusammengekommen sind um
zu besprechen welche maßnahmen zu
ergreifen sind damit unser land und
durch die nächste zeit kommt
lassen sie mich noch eines vorweg sagen
ich kann jeden und jede verstehen die
nichts mehr hören will von corona von
station und neuen virus fabian doch wir
können und dürfen nicht die augen
verschließen vor dieser nächsten welle
die sich vor uns aufzutun beginnt
im augenblick befinden wir uns noch in
einer seltsam zwischenzeit die maßnahmen
auf die wir uns ende november
verständigt haben würden überall und
flächendeckend gehen die
infektionszahlen deutlich zurück wir uns
das robert koch institut meldet ganz
allmählich verringert sich sogar auch
die belegung der intensivstation etwas
auch wenn die belastung der
beschäftigten weiteren sehr groß ist und
wir in einzelnen regionen an der grenze
sind
das zeigt dass unsere strengen maßnahmen
seit ende november die erwünschte
wirkung zeigen die strikten
zugangsbeschränkung für ungeimpfte der
zusätzliche schutz durch test um sowie
die starke booster kampagne der
vergangenen wochen waren richtig
willkommen die vierte welle also langsam
im griff
das wäre eigentlich eine gute nachricht
eigentlich denn diese pandemie lehrt uns
so schnell wie erhofft ist es nicht
vorbei
es droht nun bereits die welle 5 in
großbritannien dänemark und auch in den
usa ist omikron bereits auf dem
vormarsch
diese variante des virus unterscheidet
sich in nicht um wesentlichen merkmalen
von denen zuvor sie ist nach
einschätzung der fachleute was die
infektionen betrifft noch aggressiver
und sind eigenschaften die es
ermöglichen den impfschutz stellenweise
zu unterlaufen selbst zweifach geimpfte
und auch genesene laufen hohe gefahr
sich mit dieser variante anzustecken er
ist eine frische bußtag eine
auffrischungsimpfung bietet einigermaßen
schutz gegen eine infektion
und micon ist leichter ansteckend
verbreitet sich schneller und wird die
zahl der infektionen in den kommenden
wochen massiv ansteigen
darauf müssen wir uns jetzt einstellen
deshalb haben wir uns heute mit den 16
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten getroffen
noch ist omikron in deutschland nicht
flächendeckend aufgetreten aber
es ist nach derzeitiger einschätzung
bestenfalls nur eine frage von wenigen
wochen bis diese virusvariante sich auch
bei uns durchsetzen wird
deshalb müssen wir es auch jetzt darauf
vorbereiten
wir folgen dabei den ratschlägen des
wissenschaftlichen expertengremiums
wo ich zu den einzelnen maßnahmen komme
noch ein wort zum zeitpunkt von dem die
neuen maßnahmen an gelten sollen wir
haben bewusst entschieden du weißt sie
nicht vor ort schon irgendwo eingeführt
sind sie erst nach weihnachten anlaufen
zu lassen die erfahrung der vergangenen
beiden jahre haben gezeigt dass
weihnachten und ostern
auch durch die
verhaltensweise der bürgerinnen und
bürger sich nicht als große pandemie
treiber erwiesen haben im gegenteil die
ferien haben die infektionszahlen bürger
oft verringert die familien schein
verantwortungsvoll und vorsichtig mit
diesen festtagen umzugehen im
beschränkten rahmen mit ausreichend
estore der nötigen vorsicht
auch für diese festtage wünsche ich mir
dass möglichst viele wieder so vorgehen
um sich um ihre eltern und großeltern
ihre lieben zu schützen mit abstand mit
masken und mit zusätzlichen täglichen
tests auch wenn sie schon zweimal
geimpft sind testen sie sich bitte bevor
sie mit anderen menschen für die
weihnachtsfeiern zusammenkommen
diese pandemie hat uns in den
vergangenen 21 monaten gemeinsam sehr
viel abverlangt deshalb freuen sich
viele zu recht auf diese festtage im
trauten kreis der familie mit der
gebotenen vorsicht unter gewordenen
rücksicht ist das auch mit
die impfungen sind ein ganz wichtiger
faktor im kampf gegen monika seit dem 18
november läuft unsere booster kampagne
bis zu 30 millionen impfungen bis
weihnachten habe ich und haben wir als
ziel ausgegeben viel spricht dafür dass
wir dieses ziel erreichen werden
doch corinna macht keine weihnachtspause
bei unserer heutigen zusammenkunft haben
wir deshalb entschieden die impfkampagne
mit unverminderter kraft auch während
der feiertage zwischen den jahren und zu
beginn des neuen jahres fortzusetzen
als nächstes wollen wir bis ende januar
weitere 30 millionen booster impfungen
erreichen
damit werden dann drei viertel der
bürger und bürger drei mal geimpft und
die booster impfung soll künftig bereits
drei monate nach der zweiten impfung
möglich sein das kann ich hier sagen
wird auch die stadt punkt zu
unterstützen
impfen
bleibt unser ziel damit möglichst viele
forum micro geschützt sind darunter
verstehe ich nicht nur
auffrischungsimpfungen sondern auch erst
im 5 und 210 von
73,5 prozent der deutschen haben
inzwischen mindestens eine impfung als
nächstes zwischenziel möchte ich eine
impfquote von mindestens 80 prozent an
steuern wenn wir das erreicht haben
müssen wir das nächste ziel liegt bei
aller unsicherheit die es über das virus
nach wie vor gibt wissen wir einst das
risiko für nicht geimpfte erwachsene
sich zu infizieren und schwer zu
erkranken steigt durch die neue variante
noch einmal weiter
deshalb mein appell lassen sie sich
impfen zum eigenen schutz zum schutz
ihrer lieben unseren schutz von uns
allen wenn sie unsicher sind informieren
sie sich bei ihrem arzt oder ihrer
ärztin bei anderen fachleuten und fragen
sie die vielen die sich bereits haben
impfen lassen fast 60 millionen deutsche
sind inzwischen vollständig geimpft ohne
dass wir von schweren nebenwirkungen
oder langfristigen einschränkungen
ganz anders bei denjenigen die auf den
intensivstationen um ihr leben kämpfen
oder mit den langzeitfolgen der cupid
erkrankungen zu bringen haben
und so den konkreten maßnahmen die der
bund und die länder heute beschlossen
haben und die spätestens ab dem 28
dezember also gelten
erstens
mit blick auf die ersten erfahrungen mit
omikron in anderen ländern ist zu
erwarten dass die zahl der infektionen
noch bei uns deutlich ansteigen wird
mehr infizierte bedeutet einen erheblich
höheren krankenstand als in jeder
anderen phase dieser pandemie
deshalb fordern wir alle betriebe der
kritischen infrastruktur auf vor allem
feuerwehr polizei rettungsdienste
krankenhäuser die pandemie pläne zu
überarbeiten oder zu aktivieren wie sie
trotz hohen krankenstand der belegschaft
die kern versorgung aufrechterhalten
entsprechende pläne werden so
vorbereitet übrigens auch für
elektrizitätsversorgung und andere
bereiche dazu gehören damit sie schnell
und unkompliziert wirken
zweitens
die harten beschränkung für ungeimpfte
bleiben erhalten 3g am arbeitsplatz das
heißt nur wer geimpft oder gelesen oder
tagesaktuell getestet es darf an seinen
arbeitsplatz gehen oder bus und bahn
benutzen
noch strenger ist es im einzelhandel in
kinos und theatern hier haben nur
geimpfte oder genesene zutritt es gilt
also die 2g regel und manchmal zweig
plus und je nach regionalen pandemie
geschehen kann für die geimpften gewesen
eben dieser zusätzliche tests nötig sein
das waren wir schon erwähnt als
angeblich
außerdem gelten die strikten auflagen
für private begegnungen von ungeimpften
weiter es sind nur treffen im eigenen
haushalt und mit maximal zwei personen
aus einem anderen haushalt erlaubt das
gilt auch für die weihnachtsfeiertage
ich darf die bürgerinnen und bürger
eindringlich darum bitten sich an diese
regeln zu halten sie sind keine sie
kamen sondern dienen dem schutz der
nicht geimpften und von uns ein
dritter auf genesene unvollständig
geimpfte werden wieder gewisse
beschränkungen nötig private zukunft
zusammenkünfte sind auf maximal zehn
personen beschränkt das gilt natürlich
insbesondere im hinblick auf silvester
es ist deshalb derzeit nicht mehr die
zeit für partys und gesellige abende in
großer runde kinder unter 14 jahren
werden bei dieser beschränkung auf zehn
personen wie bisher auch für wie gewohnt
nicht ein berichten
viertens clubs und diskotheken dann bis
auf weiteres geschlossen um eine
verbreitung des virus zu erschweren auch
überregionale großveranstaltungen dürfen
nicht mehr mit publikum stattfinden das
betrifft insbesondere
fußballspiele
um die krankenhäuser zu entlasten haben
wir schon vor einiger zeit beschlossen
dass der verkauf von feuerwerkskörpern
zu silvester verboten wird sie kennen
das bereits aus dem letzten jahr
gleichzeitig wird ein verbot von
ansammlung und versammlung an silvester
und neujahr gelten
meine damen und herren ich hätte ihn
gerne erfreulichere nachrichten kurz vor
den weihnachtsfeiertagen mitgeteilt
diese pandemie strengt uns alle an wir
alle sind nur wird der pandemie müde
das hilft aber nichts wir müssen
abermals zusammen stehen und auch in
vielen fällen eben distanz halten
wir müssen uns schützen und unsere
angehörigen
wenn wir das tun mit all der vernunft
die uns als menschen gegeben ist werden
wir auch gut durch die nächste krone
wird
trotz oder gerade wegen all dem wünsche
ich ihnen ihren familienangehörigen eine
besinnliche und schöne weihnachtszeit
und einen guten jahreswechsel
in der ersten woche des neuen jahres
werden wir uns mit den
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der länder erneut
zusammensetzen um die lage zu bewerten
das treffen wird am 17 dezember
stattfinden vielen dank
als nächstes wäre herr wüst an der waage
dafür herzlichen dank die erste
stellungnahme des expertenrats der
bundesregierung war eine deutliche
warnung dass 19.00 foto macht dies noch
einmal unterstrichen man spricht von
einer neuen dimension im pandemie
geschehen die omi kommunikation ist viel
ansteckender als delta
bundesminister lauterbach hat heute von
1,5 fach gesprochen und gerade wenn man
nicht gewusst hat ist kann omikron den
impfschutz teilweise unterlaufen es
drohen deshalb schwerwiegende folgen bei
den infektionszahlen für die belastung
unserer krankenhäuser und für die anzahl
der menschen in quarantäne
es geht deshalb auch um die
aufrechterhaltung unserer kritischen
infrastrukturen wir nehmen den rat
dieses expertengremium sehr sehr ernst
omikron mahnt deshalb mehr denn je zur
entschlossenheit zu politischer führung
und zu einem konsequenten und
einheitlichen handeln impfen um boostern
sind unsere stärksten waffen gegen
omikron niemand sollte deshalb mit
seiner oder ihrer impfung warten jeder
und jede sollten sich so schnell wie
möglich buchen lassen wir schaffen in
nordrhein-westfalen aktuell erteilt bis
zwei millionen impfungen pro woche und
bundesweit werden wir durch das
engagement der kommunen der erste und
alle die dabei mithelfen das ziel von 30
millionen impfdosen bis zum jahresende
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit erreichen
und die impfkampagne sollte dann so ist
auch die verabredung des heutigen tages
auch darüber hinaus auf hochtouren
weiter laufen an dieser stelle noch
einmal ein ganz herzlicher dank an alle
menschen die das möglich machen sie
leisten einen großen dienst in unserem
land und an ihren mitmenschen wir wollen
bis ende januar so ist die verabredung
weitere 30 millionen impfungen
erreichen und deshalb muss das tempo bei
dieser impfkampagne weiter hoch bleiben
das auf droht auftreten der omicron
variante er fordert auch mit
zusätzlicher dringlichkeit die
einführung einer allgemeinen impfpflicht
damalige bundesfinanzminister
vizekanzler heutige kanzler hat im
november
formuliert dass er mit einer umsetzung
im februar rechne bund und länder haben
das im beschluss vom 2 dezember
aufgegriffen das muss geld in die länder
bitten deshalb bundesregierung bundestag
die vorbereitung für die allgemeine
impfpflicht zügig voranzutreiben und
kurzfristig einen zeitplan vorzulegen
auch dieses thema verlangt tempo und
klarheit zum schutz gegen omikron gehört
auch der schutz unserer kritischen
infrastruktur es geht um daseinsvorsorge
und stromae wasserversorgung feuerwehr
polizei und an erster stelle natürlich
um die funktionsfähigkeit unseres
gesundheitswesens
professor krömer vorsitzende des
expertenrates hat heute aus england
berichtet wo ein drittel in
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in der
kritischen infrastruktur entweder
infiziert ist oder in quarantäne und
darauf muss man sich vorbereiten
frühzeitig und planvoll das ist die
verabredung des heutigen tages bund und
länder werden sich deshalb mit den
betreibern der kritischen infrastruktur
sehr eng austauschen dass die pandemie
pläne angepasst werden um vorbereitungen
zu treffen wir müssen gewährleisten dass
die pandemiepläne so funktionieren dass
unser land auch weiterläuft wenn uns das
was england berichtete hier eher alt zum
schutz gegen um mikro empfehlen die
experten eine deutliche reduzierung der
kontakte deswegen haben wir heute ein
ganzes paket von maßnahmen beschlossen
dass der bundeskanzler gerade
vorgestellt wird das deshalb nicht
wiederholen diese maßnahmen sind das
fundament unseres schutz falls gegen
omikron bund und länder brauchen in
dieser lage aber auch darüber hinaus
eine klare strategie für die nächsten
wochen und dazu gehört dass wir uns am
nachmittag des 7 januar erneut hier
treffen werden um über das weitere
vorgehen zu beraten die bundesregierung
hat auf bitten der länder
zugesagt bis dahin eine konkrete planung
vorzulegen so brauchen als grundlage für
unsere beratungen anfang januar konkrete
vorschläge für etwaig notwendige
maßnahmen die mit dem expertenrat
abgestimmt sind wir werden außerdem über
gegebenenfalls notwendige rechtliche
änderungen sprechen müssen und über die
anpassung der wirtschaftlichen
hilfsinstrumente für die betroffenen
bereiche
wichtig ist aus meiner sicht
abschließend dass bundesregierung auch
länder bei ihren planungen auch
zukünftig den expertenrat des rk ii
einbezieht das robert koch institut das
ja eine bundesbehörde ist hat heute kurz
vor der mpk empfehlungen vorgelegt die
mit den auffassungen bundesregierung
einigen teilen nicht übereinstimmen und
über die empfehlung des expertenrates
hinausgehen man muss sich ja nicht in
jedem einzelnen punkt die auffassung des
rk ii teilen aber es ist aus meiner
sicht wichtig dass dem rk ii der respekt
entgegengebracht wird den es verdient
das lka hat mit seiner arbeit in den
letzten monaten der pandemie in
deutschland viele menschenleben gerettet
insgesamt ist heute das signal wichtig
dass bund und länder bei der bekämpfung
von omikron beim schutz der menschen in
unserem land hand in hand arbeiten
die lage ist ernst und deshalb brauchen
wir entschlossenheit konsequenz und ein
gemeinsames vorgehen
vielen dank dann als drittes die
regierende bürgermeister
meine damen und herren ich will betonen
dass es glaube ich ein sehr wichtiges
zeugnis dass diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute drei
tage vor weihnachten noch einmal
zusammen gekommen ist und auch eine
orientierung gibt für die kommenden
feiertage für das
signal und den wunsch auch an die
bevölkerung das verantwortungsbewusst
diese kommenden feiertag begangen werden
so das weihnachtsfest als auch der
jahreswechsel es geht darum dass wir
eben alle auch wenn wir uns freuen auf
die begegnung mit familien mit freunden
sehr sehr
verantwortungsvoll uns überlegen wie
können wir unsere kontakte einschränken
wenn man sich trifft möglichst eben das
schützen das testen das impfen in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen und es ist ganz
klar dass angesichts dieser lage wir
auch uns keine pause erlauben können was
das impfen angeht die impfkampagne muss
auch über die feiertage weiter laufen
mit nur sehr geringen
runter fahrenden aspekten vielleicht am
heiligabend am ersten feiertag aber auch
wir in berlin haben uns natürlich
genauso wie alle anderen bundesländer
ganz klar das ziel gesetzt diese tage
weiter zu nutzen wir sind darauf
angewiesen dass viele dabei mithelfen
sowohl die hausärzte die auch zwischen
den jahren mithelfen beim impfen als
auch unsere impfzentren die mobilen im
teams und auch die kreativen
impfaktionen an besonderen orten gerade
für kinder für jugendliche für familien
es ist wichtig dass wir alle kräfte noch
einmal zusammen nehmen auch gerade jetzt
in diesen tagen das impfen weiter
voranzubringen das boostern
voranzubringen ich bin sehr froh dass
wir in berlin mittlerweile ein drittel
der berlinerinnen und berliner
gemeistert haben und bei einer impfrate
von fast 75 prozent
sind was die erstimpfung angeht bei den
zweit impfungen auch über die 70 prozent
hinaus natürlich werden wir auch dieses
ziel verfolgen was olaf scholz erwähnt
hat auf die 80 und zu zu bewegen und
beim bus dann noch weiter auszubauen wir
haben heute von bundesminister
lauterbach gehört dass er für eine
verlässliche impfstoff beschaffung
aufsteht ich finde das sehr wichtig dass
er also uns auch in aussicht gestellt
hat dass mindestens zehn millionen
impfdosen in der woche zur verfügung
gestellt werden auch bis in den januar
ende januar hinein diese planung schon
heute auch angekündigt hat das ist sehr
wichtig dass es hier eine
verlässlichkeit gibt auch in bezug auf
weitere medikamente und impfstoffe
die auch neu auf den markt kommen werden
ich finde außerdem wichtig dass wir ein
klares signal für die kinder impfung
setzen das ist ja erst seit wenigen
tagen möglich dass die fünf- bis
elfjährigen auch einen impfstoff
bekommen ich kann aus berlin sagen dass
die impfkampagne hier sehr gut
angelaufen ist und ich werde auch in
meiner ja jetzt heute beginnenden
amtszeit übermorgen ein auch
zusätzliches signal setzen wir werden im
roten rathaus in berlin eine impfaktion
für kinder stattfinden lassen das ist
nur ein teilaspekt aber ich glaube dass
es wichtig ist eben hier auch nochmal
die eltern die familien anzusprechen und
auch mit den mobilen impf teams in die
einrichtung zu gehen für menschen die
behinderung haben für menschen die in
anderer weise nicht so mobil sind wenn
die menschen nicht in die ins zentrum
kommen können müssen wir alles dafür tun
dass die impfstoffe eben zu den menschen
kommen können die schwierigkeiten haben
eben die
angebote bei den hausärzten und den
impfzentren wahrzunehmen deswegen muss
es auf drei solide füße gestellt werden
was wir beim impfen tun die impfzentren
auf der einen seite die mobilen im teams
auf der anderen seite und auch eben das
was durch die hausärzte und auch durch
kreative orte des impfens eben
ermöglicht werden kann ich finde sehr
wichtig dass wir auch heute hier ein
signal in richtung wirtschaft gesetzt
haben die überbrückungshilfe 4 die eben
den besonders betroffenen unternehmen
auch noch mal zusätzlich zur seite
gestellt wird die korona schutzmaßnahmen
wie eben bestimmte unternehmen bestimmte
branchen besonders hart treffen es ist
wichtig dass wir das signal von dieser
ministerpräsident konferenz auch ende
des jahres eben setzen das finanzielle
unterstützung weiter zur verfügung
gestellt wird und dass eben die härte
für hilfen inklusive der sonderregelung
für die veranstaltungswirtschaft als
auch der sonderform des bundes für
messen und ausstellungen der sonderfonds
des bundes für kulturveranstaltungen und
das programm corona hilfen im profisport
ist all diese maßnahmen verlängert
werden sollen das ist ein wichtiges
signal für die wirtschaft in unseren
ländern und ein zeichen dass wir eben
jetzt auch in die umsetzung vor ort dann
gehen um eben die länder verantwortung
zu übernehmen damit diese hilfen auch
tatsächlich vor ort ankommen können und
ansonsten es ist ganz klar
weihnachten ist die zeit an dem man in
der wir zusammen kommen mit unseren
familien aber es ist auch in diesem jahr
ganz besonders die zeit der achtsamkeit
der gegenseitigen solidarität
und auch silvester würden nicht die zeit
der großen party sein sondern des
verantwortungsvollen umgangs mit dieser
situation und deshalb ein großer acker
kontakte zu reduzieren und andererseits
die haben wir schon viele viele male
gesagt immer wieder können wir es nur
sagen diejenigen die gepustet sind
werden einen besseren schutz auf
umgekommen umgekommen haben einen viel
besseren schutz und deswegen der aufruf
bitte nutzen sie all diese angebote und
der dank an all diejenigen die dabei
mithelfen dass auch in den feiertagen
diese aktionen stattfinden und wir den
schutz unserer bevölkerung auch dadurch
verstärken und gewährleisten können
vielen dank dann habe ich schon fünf
wortmeldung die erste kristina dunz ende
herr bundeskanzler das
robert-koch-institut hat ja alarmierend
heute
darauf verwiesen dass es sofort maximale
kontakt beschränkungen geben sollten
könnten sie den dissenz zur
bundesregierung
erklären ist dass jetzt mehr panikmache
des lka oder haben sie es einfach nicht
übers herz gebracht den menschen
weihnachten zu verderben und deswegen
kontakt beschränkungen erst ab 28
dezember und an den ministerpräsidenten
und die regierende bürgermeisterin
trocken
das abgeordnetenhaus hat heute die
epidemische lage beschlossen sind sie
beide herr wüst und sie der ansicht dass
es ein fehler war dass das bundesweit
ausgelaufen ist und sollte der
bundeskanzler scholz mit der ampel
koalition dies im bund wieder einführen
st
schönen dank für ihre frage wir haben ja
einen sehr großen fortschritt in unserer
beratung über die notwendigen maßnahmen
indem wir einen expertenrat eingerichtet
haben der sich mit der frage beschäftigt
was zu tun ist die qualitative
verbesserung des beratungsprozesses der
politik liegt darin dass wir die dort
versammelten expertinnen und experten
bitten und sein wort um zu ermitteln aus
ihrer diskussion die sie miteinander
führen das hat auch gute wirkung gehabt
sie sehen dass die vorschläge am
sonntagnachmittag präsentiert worden
sind und das hat noch am sonntag
beratung gegeben und den verschiedenen
gesprächsgruppen von
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten es hat am montag
intensive beratung gegeben sämtliche
chefs der senats- und
staatskanzleien und der chefin der
senatskanzlei und es hat heute noch
einmal intensive beratung gegeben so
dass wir in kürzester zeit von
gewissermaßen
sonntagabend bis heute nachmittag einen
konsens entwickelt haben über die
schritte die aus diesen empfehlung des
expertengremiums folgen
und diese entscheidung sind ja
einstimmig getroffen worden
einschliesslich der vertreter des lka
dabei dass ich glaube ich ein
fortschritt findet der zusammenarbeit
ansonsten bin ich sehr dankbar für die
arbeit die das r kelly leistet in den
letzten jahren und auch in den nächsten
jahren das sind ja immer wieder neue
vorschläge für unsere politischen
beratung und da werden werden sicherlich
auch noch viele bekommen was wir jetzt
haben ist
sofortige kontakt beschränkungen
und zwar in ergänzung zu denen die wir
schon haben im vergleich zu vielen
anderen ländern um uns herum hat
deutschland weitreichende kontakt
beschränkungen sind relativ frühzeitig
auf den weg gebracht das unterscheidet
uns das wäre zweig für geschäfte
restaurants für hotels zweig plus für
viele bereiche gemacht haben auch für
kinos kulturveranstaltungen alles
mögliche ist sehr beschränkt wir haben
das erste mal 3g am arbeitsplatz
eingeführt das hatten wir lange nicht
also alle müssen geimpft sein oder von
einer infektion genesen oder aber sich
tagesaktuell getestet haben wir haben 3g
für den öffentlichen verkehr wir haben
weitreichende kosten trage pflichten wir
haben sehr erhebliche beschränkungen in
allen bereichen durchgesetzt und
umgesetzt einschließlich testens und
masken tragen in den schulen und diese
vielen maßnahmen haben ihre guten tag
gehabt und auf die setzen wir jetzt noch
etwas oben drauf ich habe die maßnahmen
schon genannt die maßnahmen jetzt
unmittelbar greifen das ist die frage
der beschränkung von kontakten den
privaten bereich auch bei den fans
über das maß hinaus das wir bisher schon
hatten dass es die schließung von clubs
und diskotheken und das ist die
maßnahmen hätten auf großveranstaltungen
den versiegenden also sehr verfassten
umsetzung und in dieser linie verstehe
ich auch die empfehlung der von dem
institut bekommen haben
wenn ich anfangen darf soll sich die
frage gerne sehr klar beantworten wann
wenn nicht jetzt vor uns haben wir eine
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
insofern ist der beschluss dass sie
nicht fort gelten möge nach meiner sicht
aus meiner sicht ein klarer fehler
also ich würde hier nicht von einem
kleinen fehler sprechen es geht darum
dass die beendigung der lage in einer
anderen lage entschieden worden ist wir
haben seitdem eine entwicklung die dazu
führt dass neue maßnahmen ergriffen
werden müssen diese maßnahmen werden
jetzt ergriffen und es ist wichtig dass
alle maßnahmen die wir ergreifen
verhältnismäßig sind und dass wenn wir
maßnahmen ergreifen uns auch an sehen
inwieweit diese wirksam sind und dann
weitere maßnahmen gegebenenfalls
ergreifend und genau in dieser situation
befinden wir uns jetzt sind heute schon
noch mal zusätzliche schritte
entschieden worden wir werden am 7
januar wieder zusammenkommen werden dann
auch bewerten inwiefern omikron
sich entwickelt hat wird werden in
dieser zeit alles dafür tun das
infektionsgeschehen so zu minimieren wie
weit es möglich ist und dann auch
darüber zu beraten haben inwieweit eine
erneute pandemische lage zu entscheiden
ist aber für den heutigen tag und für
die jetzige situation
sind angemessene maßnahmen entschieden
worden jetzt geht es darum die auch
entsprechend umzusetzen und es geht wie
gesagt bei allem was wir tun schon auch
um verhältnismäßigkeit und deswegen wir
haben das ende in einer lage oder ist
darüber entschieden worden
wie anders war als jetzt und bei allem
was wir tun geht es schon darum sich
anzuschauen in welcher situation sind
wir und wenn die situation eben nicht
mehr so gravierend ist dann muss man
sich auch wieder über das zurücknehmen
von maßnahmen gedanken machen jetzt sind
wir in einer anderen lage deswegen ist
es gut dass wir heute diese
beschlusslage haben und alles weitere
wird im januar dann sehr zeitnah auch zu
bewerten seien
das nicht so habe ich kurz zum bäcker
von alte
herr scholz kurz zwei verständnisfragen
die schließung von clubs und diskotheken
gelten für alle bundesländer also zum
beispiel auch bremen wo sie ja
eigentlich wegen der inzidenz und weiter
offen sind und die einschränkungen mit
den zehn personen im privaten raum heißt
aber übersetzt wenn ich mit 30 leuten zu
silvester feiern möchte suche ich mir im
restaurant einfach drei separate tischen
und das ist dann möglich und herr wissen
vgh
wies sie haben ja das papier auch
angesprochen hätten sie sich gewünscht
dass genau diese maßnahmen aus dem rk ii
papier heute sozusagen geschlossen
worden wären und warum ist das aus ihrer
sicht nicht passiert und frauke weil sie
haben in berlin die epidemische notlager
für berlin heute auch also nicht sie
aber der senat erklärt was ist da
sozusagen das einvernehmen auch zwischen
den ländern aber ihre ihrer empfehlung
sollten jetzt alle länder zumindest mal
auf landesebene diese epidemische
notlage aussprechen es haben ja noch
nicht alle getan vielleicht auch noch
mal an ihren wüst
schon dank für ihre frage
vielleicht ist es etwas was
neu wahrgenommen werden muss aber ich
möchte darauf hinweisen behandeln sehr
einvernehmlich
es gibt dann einvernehmlichen rat des
expertengremiums dass wir neu etabliert
haben es gibt eine schnelle
einvernehmliche beschluss frage der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wie wenn es
schon zuletzt wir sind ja schon zu
kurzen zusammengekommen haben usw
piraten wir haben auch im november einen
sehr weitreichenden beschluss auf den
weg gebracht und den ich mich sehr
bemüht habe und bei dem es um die frage
gehen wie kriegen wir das eigentlich hin
dass wir eine beschlussfassung haben bei
der mit der booster kampagne der
impfkampagne beginnen und das ist das
möchte ich gerne sagen neben der
tatsache dass wir sehr früh
weitreichende kontakt beschränkung
maßnahmen insbesondere für ungeimpfte
aber auch für viele weitere ergriffen
haben der qualitative unterschied zu
vielen anderen ländern deutschland ist
strikt da vorgegangen im bereich der
kontakt beschränkungen als nicht alle
aber die allermeisten anderen das
gleiche gilt für die frage des
bewusstseins das haben wir mit großem
tempo vorangetrieben
sie haben in den letzten tagen und
wochen sehr genau wahrgenommen wie wir
es geschafft haben dass diese kampagne
auch tatsächlich überall in deutschland
stattfindet alle 16 länder haben ihre
impfzentren wiederöffnet mobile im teams
aktiviert die ärzte und ärzten haben das
impfen mit einer ganz neuen
geschwindigkeit praktiziert und wir
erleben rekordzeit die brauchen wir auch
weil das unsere eine strategie ist im
kampf gegen die korona pandemie dass wir
das impfen und blut sondern den
vordergrund schieben und dabei hast uns
sogar etwas gelungen was wahrscheinlich
die allermeisten fast schon fatalistisch
und zu unrecht
möglich gehalten hatten nämlich dass wir
auch wieder voran kommen mit den
erstimpfung von vielen die sich bisher
noch nicht entschlossen hatten auch dort
sehen wir jetzt wie die zahlen zu nehmen
und das muss auch sein deshalb bin ich
dafür dass wir unser handeln
strukturieren durch ehrgeizige ziele die
dann aber auch dazu führen dass ganz
deutschland sich unter hakt und diese
ziele umsetzt das ehrgeizige ziel 30
millionen impfungen ab dem 18 november
zu organisieren bis ungefähr weihnachten
werden wir nach aller voraussicht
erreichen und deshalb machen wir gleich
weiter und sagen die nächsten 30
millionen den wir jetzt entdeckt wir
machen weiter zwischen den tagen wir
machen weiter und wir wollen dann in
dieser zeit auch die erst- zweit- dritt-
impfung auf den weg bringen für all
diejenigen die bisher sich noch gar
nicht habe nehmen zu lassen in diesem
monat dem nächsten monat im übernächsten
monat weil wir das hinkriegen müssen
dass wir höhere zahlen erreichen 80
prozent bei dem impfschutz für alle
wollen wir erreichen jetzt schnell aber
wenn wir das ziel erreicht habe ich
wiederhole das nochmal so weitergehen
mit dem nächsten ehrgeizigen ziel über
eine impfpflicht zu diskutieren und
nicht vorher zwischen ziele zu
formulieren die in die richtung
marschieren macht ja keinen sinn also
wenn wir bei 80 prozent sind wird es um
die 90 prozent geben nur damit ich das
schon mal ankündige wir wollen nicht
beobachter seien der entwicklung in
unserem land sollen tätige tätig sein
und aktivitäten unternehmen das gleiche
gilt im übrigen für die maßnahmen die
sich auf die kritische infrastruktur
richten das ist besonders bemerkenswert
dass wir das jetzt schon in den blick
nehmen wir warten nicht ab dass probleme
passiert sind sondern für hypothetische
mögliche entwicklung treffen wir jetzt
vorsorge dann wird all die bereiche der
kritischen infrastruktur von den
elektrizitätswerken bis zu
krankenhäusern polizei feuerwehr und so
weiter in der lage sind ihren betrieb
unvermindert in allen zeiten aufrecht zu
erhalten unter diskutieren wir jetzt
auch über viele folgemaßnahmen die
daraus sortieren und das umsetzen zu
können
übrigens eine gute botschaft in diesem
zusammenhang ist das jetzt ja weitere
impfstoffe zugelassen werden die für
diejenigen attraktiv sind die sich mit
dem bisherigen nicht haben anfreunden
kann und das wird unsere kampagnen noch
viel mehr zur impfung zu bewegen auch
noch mal neu unterstützen also ich
glaube deutschland geht hier einen
klaren strengen wie ich und dass wir uns
in ganz kurzer zeit wieder treffen zeigt
dass wir auch einen präzisen plan
verfolgen was wir brauchen ist
koordiniertes handeln ist klarheit im
kopf klarheit dem und das bedeutet auch
dass wir es miteinander machen dass die
zeit vorbei sind der jeden tag jemand
eine neue meldung produziert immer was
zu tun wäre sondern dass wir lieber
schnell und zusammen diskutieren und
handeln und gemeinsam agieren dass es
geschehen und das ist ein gutes zeichen
denn die zeiten werden nicht einfach ja
werde ich zum erliegen
[Musik]
dann mach ich dann fertig also wenn ich
zum rk ii
eben was gesagt habe dann deshalb weil
nicht der respekt und der schutz der
institution wichtig ist wenn sie die
nachrichten tagsüber verfolgen auch
einzelne zitate die dann das licht der
öffentlichkeit erblickt haben aus
unseren beratungen glaube ich versteht
jeder dass das angezeigt er gewesen ist
ja die informationslage seitens des
bundes im weitesten sinne war chaotisch
und hat auch zu verunsicherungen im
heutigen tage geführt expertenvotum auf
der einen seite rk als ob das der
bundesbürger auf der anderen seite das
mag man auch kritisieren aber
die institution deshalb zu kritisieren
wie ich das teilweise
aus
medienberichten enorm habe ist
unangemessen und deswegen habe ich dem
leben für mich klar widersprochen wir
brauchen eine solche institution die uns
an vielen stellen ja auch geholfen hat
in den letzten monaten menschenleben zu
schützen und darum geht ist deswegen
muss ich mir nicht über die ganze zeit
und auch nicht heute jede einzelne
forderung zu eigen machen aber man soll
die institution ernst nehmen auch in
zukunft das thema länderöffnungsklausel
ich habe jetzt hier nicht die aufgabe
anderen ländern zu sagen was sie tun
sollen wie sie rechtstechnisch ihre
dinge umzusetzen haben sind hier aufgabe
des npd-vorsitzenden wir nordrhein
westfalen haben sie genutzt
dazu es gibt ja eine sehr große klarheit
was zu tun ist über die empfehlung die
einstimmige empfehlung des expertenrates
und diese einstimmige empfehlung ist ja
auch die grundlage für den mp am schluss
ja heute gefasst worden ist ich sehe
nicht dass es da eine unklarheit gibt
sondern es gibt eine klare orientierung
darauf dass man politische beschlüsse
fasst auf der grundlage einer empfehlung
die ein eingesetztes gremium gegeben hat
um hier mit rat und tat zur seite zu
stehen das haben wir gemacht und
deswegen gibt es da eine sehr große
klarheit und ich will nicht dem
anschließend was er wisse auch gesagt
hat es geht nicht darum zu sagen jetzt
müssen alle länder genau identisch den
gleichen weg gehen sondern es ist immer
gut wenn es einheitliche
rahmenbedingungen gibt auf die wir uns
verständigt haben heute aber wenn es
auch die möglichkeit gibt dass die
länder eben anhand ihrer regionalen
gegebenheiten anhand ihres regionalen
infektionsgeschehen es orientierte
spezifische massnahmen treffen können
und deswegen muss dass jedes bundesland
auch für sich entscheiden ob es eine
solche epidemische lage feststellt
inwieweit die instanzen auch aussehen in
berlin hat das abgeordnetenhaus das
heute bestätigt
und hat eben auf die vorlage des senats
da entsprechend auch reagiert wir haben
das so eingestuft und werden
dementsprechend auch heute nach der mpk
beschlussfassung eben diese maßnahmen
noch am donnerstag in der senatssitzung
entsprechend umsetzen in einer neuen
verordnung war das muss immer anhand
auch der jeweiligen infektions lage im
jeweiligen bundesland passieren und das
ist ja auch gut dass es diese
möglichkeit gibt anhand einheitlich
vereinbarte rahmenbedingungen in der mpk
und anhand der konkreten lage vor ort
über die geeigneten verhältnismäßigen
und wirksamen maßnahmen auf zu
entscheiden und ich will das auch noch
mal betonen olaf scholz hat sehr kurz
erwähnt wir haben tatsächlich auch in
berlin rekordzahlen beim impfen auch bei
den erstimpfung auch bei den
jugendlichen
65 prozent der 12 bis 17 jährigen die
mittlerweile ihre erste impfung bekommen
haben über die hälfte die zweitimpfung
das sind schon deutliche signale ein
sehr hoher zuspruch beim kinder im wir
sehen also es gibt auch gerade bei den
jüngeren bei den eltern bei den familien
dort ein großes interesse durch die
zusätzlichen angebote auch eine
wahrnehmung dieser angebote das ist
genau der richtige weg das wird eben
alles daraufsetzen in verschiedenen
angeboten in verschiedenen möglichkeiten
um die menschen auch dazu zu überzeugen
um entsprechend hier auch diese ziel
sein zu erreichen und zunächst einmal
auch auf das angebot zu setzen bevor
eine pflicht denn oder die nächsten
schritte für eine pflicht auch dann
gegangen werden so ich habe noch fünf
fragen hat der regierenden
bürgermeisterin versprochen dass sie
nicht zu spät zur konstituierenden
sitzung ihre senates kommt insofern
lände dass so ein bisschen kondensieren
den fragen und warum er von den
antworten dann kommen wir gut durch und
müssen berlin nicht unregierbar machen
frau münch ist die nächste
guten abend auch von mir herr scholz
herr lauterbach hat vor ziemlich genau
zwei wochen das ziel ausgegeben dass man
zu weihnachten reisen wieder empfehlen
können soll können sie das jetzt mit
gutem gewissen zu tun oder haben sie das
ziel verfehlt und die bundesregierung
redet auch in diesem jahr zu weihnachten
von reisen ab und eine frage an alle
woher nehmen sie die zuversicht dass die
maßnahmen vor allem von den ungeimpften
auch befolgt werden denn viele
ungeimpfte sind ja grund skeptisch würde
ich sagen was die pandemien
die empfehlung die wir geben dem
beschluss den die
bundesregierung so der bundeskanzler
zusammen mit den regierungschefin und
regierungschefs der länder gerade
gefasst hat und auf die konzentrieren
wir uns das sind die kontakte schränken
die wir haben und ansonsten sagen dann
vorsichtig insbesondere wenn ihr euch
mit euren freunden zumal nach dem
treffen familie beachtet dort halt die
vorsichtsregeln das steht auch in den
text noch mal wieder das sind die dinge
die wir vorschlagen und nicht andere
daneben sonst hätten wir sie in den text
und im vorschläge aufgenommen es sind
sehr weitreichende maßnahmen das für
dich noch mal ausdrücklich dazu sagen
und sie werden auch dazu beitragen dass
wir weiter vorankommen nochmal alle
maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben führen
dazu dass wir
gegen da hatte ich eine verbesserte lage
haben wir sind nur klug beraten zum
beispiel dass expertengremien und da
dass er und viele andere und essen aus
der sicht auf andere länder das ist mit
omikron noch mal wieder anders werden
wird und wir uns jetzt nicht trüben
lassen dürfen von der guten entwicklung
die wir gerade sehen und deshalb greifen
wir auch die entscheidende maßnahme die
dazu wichtig ist nämlich irgendwie gut
an alles das was damit verbunden ist und
andere auch entsprechend die kraft
eingelegt dass wenn das voranbringen
neben den kontakt beschränkung neben den
maßnahmen zur kritischen infrastruktur
also dass die maßnahmen natürlich auch
umgesetzt werden müssen ist ja völlig
klar man sieht daran halten muss einmal
1 sehen wir schauen immer auf die die
sich nicht daran halten aber die
allermeisten alten sicher
jenseits der letzten details des
geschriebenen rechts löst das was wir
tun ja etwas aus bei den menschen wir
sind vorsichtig sie nehmen rücksicht sie
passen sich an die tragen wieder
vermehrt maske das muss man glaube ich
immer wieder unterstreichen und dann für
alle anderen adressieren wir natürlich
auch nicht nur appelle sondern es geht
auch kontrolliert vielen stellen sind es
natürlich nur stichproben sei denn wir
reden von zugangskontrollen in
bestimmten bereichen wo man natürlich
dann besser kontrollieren kann ich kann
nur für mein land sprechen wir
unterstützen die ordnungsbehörden die ja
kommunaler behörden sind auch mit
landesmitteln dass man da mehr machen
kann wenn mit den normalen ausstattung
eines normalen das amt sieht man dass
nicht alles hinkriegen deswegen
unterstützen wir schon länger getan und
verschiedenen stellen uns jetzt nochmal
zusätzlich um da auch einen gewissen
kontrolldruck zu haben wir haben auch
die bußgelder erhöht und im grunde ist
es am ende doch wie im straßenverkehr
nicht jeder verstoß wird in jedem moment
geahndet aber doch so oft und durch die
bußgelder auch so spürbar dass sich die
allermeisten menschen dran halten
sind viele noch zu überzeugen und
überzeugen sich gerade die teile den
pessimismus nicht der sich gelingen
nicht verbreitet und ich glaube dass
ganz viele
einfach durch die art ihres lebens nicht
dazu gekommen sind sie keinen weg
gefunden haben andere prioritäten hatten
dass viele auch sorgen hatten dass die
verschiedenen möglichkeiten betrifft und
natürlich beeindruckt von beiden das
gesetz erleben erstens den vielen
bürgern und bürger nennt des landes die
sich schon vollständig haben impfen
lassen sind ja immerhin über 70 prozent
die einen vollständigen impfschutz haben
es geht weiter nach oben wir wollen
jetzt die 80 prozent erreichen und dann
weit nach vorne gehen und umgekehrt
ermöglichen ja auch die erfahrung dann
mit der neuen virus stelle noch mal
darüber nachzudenken ob es nicht besser
sich impfen zu lassen und das will ich
an dieser stelle noch einmal mit
nachdruck unterstreichen der nicht
geimpft ist ein risiken
großen
risiko ausgesetzt
infiziert zu werden zu erkranken
möglicherweise schwer und dafür gibt es
dann keinen schutz wenn man sich nicht
impfen lassen und das überzeugt
vielleicht die eine oder den anderen
auch noch und deshalb finde ich sollten
wir schon beieinander bleiben und im
übrigen weiß ich darauf fielen die sich
bisher nicht anknüpfen lassen dass sie
sich trotzdem sehr vorsichtig vor weil
sie schon wissen dass coruna gefährlich
ist und deshalb bin ich zuversichtlich
dass wir das hinbekommen viele hinter
diesem weg zu versammeln
kirchner von der deutschen welle und
danach hat jahres
war bundeskanzler sie haben mehrfach
darauf verwiesen dass deutschland früher
kontakt beschränkungen eingeführt hat
als einige europäische nachbarn was sind
in deutschlands erwartungen an die
europäischen nachbarn jetzt und haben
sie heute in dieser runde oder denkt
deutschland allgemein über neue
maßnahmen im hinblick auf omikron an den
deutschen grenzen nach und dann herrn
wüst die kurze frage bundeskanzler
scholz hat von einvernehmlichkeit
gesprochen haben sie das heute auch so
empfunden und frau gefallen wenn sie von
einer handlungsgrundlage sprechen meinen
sie damit ein minimalkonsens und
wünschen sie sich dass auch andere
bundesländer so ähnlich wie hamburg
maßnahmen früher einführen als den 28
wir haben über die maske angesprochen
und das regime das zu geschehen hat in
bezug auf nachbarländer ist ja
bekannt es werden gegenseitig viele
unserer nachbarstaaten als hochrisiko
länder eingestuft wegen der entwicklung
dort und das geht immer hin und her wird
das jetzt die ganze zeit luft gegangen
ist also wir haben da ein sehr
etabliertes vorgehen dass wir uns ab
betrachten und natürlich gucken wie sie
lagert immer wieder neu an verabredet
haben heute was wir hier aufgeschrieben
haben
warum das auch gleich mit zu beantworten
und zwar einvernehmlich sonst hat es
keinen beschluss und schon auch die
terminfindung war unproblematisch und
einvernehmlich und zügig um das in
abgrenzung zu dem was wir in der
jüngeren vergangenheit erlebt haben auch
klar zu unterstreichen
also ich kann mir noch einen
ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen erinnern die so waren dass
wir uns denn
irgendwann mitten in der nacht oder am
frühen morgen zur pressekonferenz
versammelt haben dass die tatsache dass
heute diese ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ja gerade mal zwei stunden gedauert hat
und dann ein fertiger beschlussvorlage
zeigt eigentlich schon wie
einvernehmlich die situation und die
diskussion auch
verlaufen sind und das ist natürlich zu
einzelnen punkten auch gesprächsbedarf
gibt das ist klar aber es war sehr gut
vorbereitet und wir sind jetzt an einer
verständigung die alle umsetzen können
für die kontakt beschränkung ist ja auch
ein spätestens zum 28
dezember vereinbart worden das heißt die
bundesländer können jetzt je nachdem
wann die kabinette auch entsprechend
tagen gegebenenfalls das auch früher
machen aber ich will einfach sagen wir
reden hier wirklich über ganz wenige
tage und wir haben dazwischen eben das
weihnachtsfest und ich glaube es ist
völlig in ordnung dass jetzt in der
umsetzung
mit diesem spätestens 28 dezember auch
agiert wird und die bundesländer die
möglichkeit haben das entsprechend auch
vor ort umzusetzen innerhalb der
nächsten wenigen tage verbunden mit den
aufrufen an die bevölkerung ja auch
dennoch ihre eigenen jeweiligen
entscheidungen im familiären umfeld im
freundeskreis auch zu treffen um auch
jenseits von verordnungen erlassen
werden durch das signal das heute durch
den beschluss gesetzt worden ist auch
das eigene handeln zu überdenken und im
eigenen umfeld auch eigene
vorsichtsmaßnahmen treffen ich glaube so
viel eigenverantwortung und
selbstbestimmte können wir wirklich
unserer verantwortungsvollen bevölkerung
auch zutrauen und wie gesagt ich sehe
auch wie viele menschen wirklich auch
sich an die maßnahmen halten und sehr
vorsichtig und sehr verantwortungsvoll
sind und ich finde das muss man auch
sehen und auch denjenigen danken die das
über so viele monate gemacht haben und
all den anderen natürlich durch klare
regeln durch auch kontrollen und
konsequente gegebenenfalls auch
sanktionen etwas entgegensetzen als
nächstes jahres ort von bild sondern
nach andreas tun ist
sie haben eingangs gesagt der
bundeskanzler dass sie sich am 17 januar
wieder treffen werden können sie
ausschließen dass es vorher noch meine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geben wird
das geschehen der pandemie verlangt dass
für jederzeit handlungsfähig sind
deshalb kann überhaupt niemand mit dem
satz was anfangen was man ausschließen
kann das wird ja nicht weiter aber wir
haben sehr genau in den blick genommen
dass wir uns hier zügig treffen müssen
und deshalb auch auf den siebten die
haben nur geeinigt und das gehört dazu
sowohl der experten unsere experten
gremiums expertenrat als auch wir alle
werden über die tage weiter arbeiten als
regierung zusammen mit den ländern mit
allen leuten die wir zu rate ziehen der
krisenstaat weiter arbeiten wir werden
die impfkampagne überall weiterführen
also da hört jetzt nicht alles auf und
am 17 januar geht es weiter sondern in
der zwischenzeit beschäftigen wir uns
auch noch mit was anderem aber sehr viel
jeden tag egal wo er sich aufhält mit
diesem thema
herr scholz mit bezug auf das
überraschende auftauchen des papiers vom
robert koch institut heute hat ja bist
gerade von einer chaotischen
informationslage gesprochen die zu
verunsicherung geführt hat da
interessiert uns natürlich sehen sie das
auch so und sehen sie grund in der
kommunikations leistung des bundes
irgendwas zu verbessern der bund hat
eine sehr gute kommunikation organisiert
hat ein expertengremium einberufen das
ratschläge gegeben wird die haben wir
sofort kommuniziert so dass das denn die
beratung vieler länder schon am sonntag
eingeschlossen ist ich habe sehr viel
telefoniert
und da man mit wüst aber nicht nur mit
ihm auch an dem sonntag und dazu alles
beigetragen dass wir aus diesem
schlussfolgerung schnell ein ergebnis
ziehen ich unterstreiche dass ich die
these des ak in den letzten wochen
monaten und den letzten zwei jahren ganz
besonders wichtig gefunden hat und auch
weiter wichtig finden werde und trotzdem
bin ich sehr froh dass wir jetzt genau
das gemacht haben was wir uns
zusammen vorgenommen haben als
gemeinschaft von bundeskanzler und
regierungschefin regierungschefs der
länder nämlich dass wir diesen rat uns
anschauen und dann auch schnell umsetzen
das glaube ich hat es noch nicht gegeben
dass wir sonntag nachmittag das ergebnis
haben und dienstagnachmittag die
beschlüsse ist schon was
dann habe ich als letzten fragesteller
martin lorber vom spiegel
der gucken hand herr bundeskanzler sehen
sie eine notwendigkeit oder möglichkeit
den gesetzgeber
dazu anzuregen die impfpflicht noch
etwas schneller in gang zu setzen also
vielleicht schon im januar oder wollen
sie bewusst diese zeit auch nutzen um zu
sehen ob diese pflicht dann überhaupt
noch notwendig ist wenn sich genügend
gekämpft haben und an sie alle drei die
frage ob mann ob sie darüber geredet
haben dass man die quarantäne regeln für
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in der
kritischen infrastruktur vielleicht auf
weichen muss ähnlich wie es in der
ersten welle war dass ärzte mit leichten
symptomen trotzdem zur arbeit gegangen
sind
zunächst mal was war die erste schicht
also ja genau ich hatte die zweite frage
beantworte ich zuerst also ja haben
darüber geredet ob die
anpassungen notwendig ist aber wir
wollen uns fachlich beraten lassen
insbesondere aks da dran die frage zu
durchdenken und dass es keinen punkt für
schnellschüsse gehört aber zu den
vorbereitungen auf eine situation wo es
möglicherweise
viele gibt die
erkrankt sind oder in quarantäne die
keine schweren symptome haben auch zu
hause sind aber am arbeitsplatz film und
was das bedeutet und wie man damit
umgehen kann
wie lange garantien andauern müssen wenn
man sicher weiß dass wenn man sich nicht
infiziert hat und ähnliches das muss
fachlich beraten werden da haben wir
alle einen großen respekt ich will das
jedenfalls für mich in anspruch nehmen
habe den eindruck das gilt für alle
anderen auch hier das wollen wir nicht
einfach mal so am tisch uns ausdenken da
wollen wir gut beraten sein und diesen
guten rat werden wir auch bekommen ich
habe in der frage der impfpflicht mich
ja positioniert ich bin dafür und
deshalb bin ich auch froh dass sie hier
noch mal wieder auftaucht wir haben hier
eine einrichtung bezogene impfpflicht
bereits etabliert und nein ich bin nicht
der meinung dass wir davon abstand
nehmen sollten wenn wir jetzt
gewissermaßen
weitere fortschritte erzielen sondern
das ist eine diskussion die hier ja
grundsätzlich erforderlich ist und das
will ich ja auch nicht verhehlen damit
das nicht so gerate stattfindet wie
manche debatten
der letzten zwei jahre so zugetragen
haben das ist ja das was wir durch
expertengremium durch schnelle umsetzung
jetzt überwinden wollen
wir
wissen dass wir eine hohe impfquoten
brauchen deshalb müssen wir bei 80
kommen wenn über 80 gekommen sind müssen
wir über 90 kommen
wir wissen dass wir jetzt nach der
zweiten impfung eine
auffrischungsimpfung brauchen die
booster impfung das mussten wir erst im
frühjahr des letzten jahres noch nicht
aber wir wissen ist jetzt seit einiger
zeit und haben uns jetzt ja auch schnell
durchgerungen genau das zu machen und es
spricht ja angesichts der impfstoff
entwicklungen viel dafür dass wir
irgendwann im laufe des nächsten jahres
die empfehlung abgeben noch eine weitere
impfung durch geeignete impfstoff zu
machen klare aussage wie es
zwischendurch bitte nicht abwarten
sondern die booster impfung hilft jetzt
sofort den schutz vor einer infektionen
steigt für diejenigen die zweimal
geimpft sind mit der dritten impfung
sofort in ganz kurzer zeit und schützt
vor krankheit aber auch vor davon dass
man ansteckend ist und schützt vor
schweren verläufen nicht
hundertprozentig aber doch so viel dass
das alles sehr sehr wirksam und sehr
empfehlenswert das sind genau das wollen
wir tun und gerade deshalb ist die
debatte nicht zu ende ich glaube auch
dass das schnell gehen muss und die
bundesregierung wird die abgeordneten
dabei unterstützen gute gesetzentwürfe
auf den weg zu bringen und das auch
schnell zu entscheiden würden zu beraten
ich jedenfalls habe mich ja positioniert
und du es hier noch bei ich halte eine
impfpflicht die dann irgendwann gilt und
umgesetzt werden kann für erforderlich
das wird uns nicht so schnell verlassen
das thema kohle
so blick auf die uhr und die berliner
senatssitzung würde diese
pressekonferenz gerne schließen ich
bedanke mich für ihr interesse und ihre
geduld und wünsche auch von dieser
stelle schon mal frohe weihnachten
vielen dank
ja das war die pressekonferenz von bund
und ländern zu schärferen corona
maßnahmen die wegen der omicron variante
kommen sollen im wesentlichen ab dem 28
dezember ich fasst die wesentlichen
punkte mal kurz zusammen da gibt es zum
einen die privaten zusammenkünfte
vollständig geimpfte und genesene sollen
mit maximal zehn personen sich
treffen können darin wäre sie jetzt auch
schriftlich
genau das ist die neuerung also
vollständig kämpfte und genießen dürfen
sich nur noch mit zehn personen treffen
bisher galt schon ungeimpfte maximal
zwei personen eines weiteren haushalts
also einen haushalt plus maximal zwei
personen eines weiteren haushalts kinder
sind davon ausgenommen in beiden fällen
geht es um kinder bis 14 jahre dann
haben wir noch neuerungen bei
veranstaltungen
clubs und diskotheken müssen schließen
ich habe gelernt im beschluss steht tanz
lustbarkeiten so steht das nämlich in
der gewerbeordnung das ist dann der
genaue begriff also die müssen schließen
und großveranstaltungen finden ab dem 28
dezember ohne zuschauer statt und dann
gibt es noch die sonstigen beschlüsse
auf des corona gipfels da geht es um die
kritische infrastruktur die
pandemiepläne sollen überarbeitet werden
dazu sind alle teile der kritischen
infrastruktur in deutschland
aufgefordert weitere 30 millionen bus
der impfungen soll es bis ende januar
geben
und ein nächstes treffen von bund und
ländern soll am 17 januar stattfinden
soweit die beschlüsse es gibt noch ein
böllerverbot das heißt es gibt diese
auch die in diesem jahr werden keine
feuerwerkskörper verkauft und an
silvester gibt es ein an und
versammlungsverbot wir wollen die
beschlüsse besprechen mit dem leiter des
zdf hauptstadtstudios in berlin mit theo
koll einen schönen guten abend schön
guten und sie haben die pressekonferenz
mit sicherheit auch verfolgt
bundeskanzler scholz hat von großer
einvernehmlichkeit gesprochen wie sehen
sie das stehen da alle teilnehmenden zu
100 prozent dahinter was heute
beschlossen wurde nein das findet sich
in ich habe mir gerade das beschluss
protokoll durchgelesen und ganz am
schluss auch klein geschrieben gibt es
eine protokollerklärung von zwei
bundesländern nämlich von baden
württemberg und sachsen und sie sagen
ausdrücklich dass ihnen das nicht reicht
das sie glauben dass die maßnahmen zu
schwach sind also das ist ein ganz ein
versteckter hinweis aber ein sehr
deutlicher hinweis dass es da deutliche
unzufriedenheiten gab ministerpräsident
kretschmann hatte ja auch im vorfeld
schon sehr deutlich gemacht dass er am
liebsten ein lockdown sich wünscht also
da waren eine ganze menge
unterströmungen die b länder das sind
die länder der union
regierungen die haben im grunde auch
versucht einige sachen noch rein zu
schreiben und wenn man sich das durch
sieht den beschluss dann findet man das
auch
beispielsweise dass die bundesregierung
verpflichtet wurde für diese nächste mpk
am 17 januar maßnahmen planungen also
eine art fahrplan vorzulegen wie es dann
weitergehen soll und sie müssen einen
plan vorlegen für die allgemeine
impfpflicht weil die hatte der
bundeskanzler ja eigentlich schon mal
für februar in aussicht gestellt und
einige ministerpräsidenten hatten das
gefühl dass das irgendwie auf dem weg
verloren ginge und insofern hat man das
noch heute in diese ganzen beschlüsse
reingeschrieben gut dass sie sagen theo
das thema impfpflicht ansprechen dazu
gibt es nämlich auch einige fragen die
damit ja schon mal beantwortet sind ja
genau in dem beschluss steht nämlich
auch dass es um eine vereinbarung geht
von bundesweit einheitliche
mindeststandards das würde doch im
prinzip bedeuten dass jetzt jede
ministerpräsidentin jeder
ministerpräsident
darüber hinaus noch gehen kann in seinem
bundesland ja das war ja bisher immer so
dass man im rahmen der möglichkeiten
dass die länder das dann individuell
anpassen können aber es ist natürlich
häufig so dass für die
bundesländer ist eine erleichterung ist
wenn man im grunde einheitliche regeln
hat weil es ja immer das leben von
menschen eingreift das ist ja die große
diskussion beim lockdown für
beispielsweise den handel wenn das dazu
führt dass geschäfte schließen müssen
oder beschränkt werden dann ist das
natürlich für jede landesregierung
eine schwierige sache umzusetzen und
wenn das einheitlich auf bundesebene
entschieden wird dann hat man im grunde
ein anderen einen anderen schuldigen
ich fand interessant heute auch das was
da passiert ist rund um das rk ii also
es gab ja offensichtlich
zufällig weil das rk ewigen der omicron
variante eine neue empfehlung
ausgearbeitet hat aber die platz der
heute im grunde in dieser sitzung und
ist insofern interessant als dass rk ii
also eine bundesbehörde
die ja auch dem gesundheitsministerium
unterstellt ist gesagt hat wir fordern
sofortige massive kontakt beschränkungen
das ist eigentlich ein anderes wort für
lockdown und das ist das gegenteil von
dem was der gesundheitsminister am
sonntag gesagt da hat sie nämlich ganz
klar gesagt wir werden keinen lockdown
vor weihnachten bekommen wie
beispielsweise in den niederlanden und
dann sagt seine behörde das rk ii genau
das fordert jahre also das war eine
kleine handgranate die da heute in die
sitzung geworfen wurde absolut das lka
hat ja von maximal infektions
präventiven maßnahmen gesprochen
tatsächlich
wenn man das als synonym für lockdown
verstehen und da soll es ja auch ärger
gegeben haben jetzt haben wir aber in
der pressekonferenz alle gesagt nein mit
dem robert koch institut gab es keinen
ärger was stimmt denn nun naja also mir
wurde von menschen die dabei waren aus
der sitzung kurz mitgeteilt dass es den
ärger gab dass der gesundheitsminister
auch gesagt hat dass können nicht ohne
folgen bleiben
ich war nicht dabei also insofern muss
ich mich darauf verlassen was daraus
gemeldet wird wir werden es vielleicht
im nachgang da noch mit mehreren quellen
belegen können ich schaue mal einmal in
den chat welche fragen es ist da gibt ja
eine frage von strawberry was es denn
jetzt mit den hotels
da gibt es keine einschränkungen also
irgendwie haben ja relativ einen ganz
klaren katalog dessen was jetzt
passieren soll sie haben es ja eben
wunderbar zusammengefasst also
spätestens ab dem 28 dezember diese
kontakt beschränkungen auch für geimpfte
also maximal zehn personen clubs und
diskotheken werden geschlossen in
hamburg hat man ja schon angekündigt
dass es sofort passiert wir werden
erleben dass großveranstaltungen ohne
zuschauer stattfinden also wohl kultur
als auch fußball das heißt also wieder
geisterspiele aber von hotel
beschränkungen ist da keine rede
jedenfalls im moment
gastronomie auch nicht es war ja in
hamburg jetzt heute so dass man dort
gesagt hat wir werden die gastronomie
insofern beschränken als wir 23 uhr
festsetzen für die schließung aber das
sind maßnahmen die hat man jetzt noch
nicht vereinbart ich mach mal eine
klammer in der ampel gibt es natürlich
da eine große diskussion weil die fdp
viele dieser maßnahmen entschieden
ablehnt für für die liberalen ist das
ein großer eingriff in die grundrechte
und eine individual liebe alle
interpretation
besagt möglichst wenig eingriffe in die
freiheit der menschen damit war die fdp
im wahlkampf und bei der wahl auch sehr
erfolgreich viele junge wähler haben die
fdp deswegen gewählt weil sie während
der pandemie im prinzip sehr lange diese
position hatte sie gesagt hat das ist
alles viel zu viel wir greifen viel zu
sehr ein und im moment scheint es mir
dass innerhalb der ampel koalition genau
dass ein teil der diskussion ist dass
die fdp große schwierigkeiten hat weiter
einzugreifen in die freiheit der
menschen wir haben es ja erlebt bei dem
infektionsschutzgesetz also wir haben
die epidemische notlage wurde
abgeschafft und es wurde ein relativ
mildes
infektionsschutzgesetz verabschiedet mit
eher weniger möglichkeiten einzugreifen
und das musste ja jetzt schon zweimal
korrigiert werden und für die fdp wäre
es wäre es sehr schwer jetzt dann einen
lock down zu verabschieden der dann
wieder massiv in das leben eingreift
aus dem chat kommen vor allem auf
youtube fragen nach den fitnessstudios
sagten wir auch ein haken dran machen da
die wahren zustand zumindest heute nicht
zur debatte
der vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
das ist ja jetzt nordrhein westfalens
ministerpräsident wüst der saß ja dann
heute links neben kanzler scholz der hat
im vorab noch auf twitter gefordert bund
und länder müssen in einer gemeinsamen
strategie den schutzwall vor der fünften
welle so hoch wie möglich bauen so hoch
wie möglich das wäre doch ein lock down
und davon ist ja nach wie vor nicht die
rede
ist sind die maßnahmen die jetzt
beschlossen wurden sind sie dass die die
der expertenrat auch gefordert hat oder
haben die weitreichendere maßnahmen
gefordert das war ganz interessant
der expertenrat hatte in seiner ersten
stellungnahme eine wirklich dramatische
beschreibung analyse der situation
eingereicht aber hat dann relativ milde
formuliert bei den maßnahmen ich hatte
den eindruck das liegt auch daran dass
man auf jeden fall einstimmig sein
wollte in diesem ersten beschluss es gab
ja sind ja 19 expertinnen und experten
in diesem rat und man hat mit 19 zu null
das verabschiedet da sind aber sehr
unterschiedliche positionen auch drin
wie beispielsweise von professor drosten
und professor strikt die ja die dinge
sehr oft unterschiedlich beurteilen und
vielleicht war das auch ein kompromiss
dass man da relativ milde maßnahmen in
das papier geschrieben hat aber die
analyse ist eigentlich dramatisch und
darauf bezog sich auch der
ministerpräsident aus nordrhein
westfalen
jetzt haben wir ja schon bund länder
runden erlebt wo die pressekonferenz
dann nach mitternacht stattgefunden hat
heute gegen das sehr relativ schnell das
waren ja dann glaube ich zwei
zweieinhalb stunden bis die
pressekonferenz stattfinden konnte
spricht das sagt das was über die
zusammenarbeit von ländern und dem neuen
kanzler scholz aus
also mir scheint dass der neue
vorsitzende der mpk also minister roland
wüstes nicht eskalieren wollte das wäre
aber möglich gewesen weil es gab im
vorfeld eine ganze reihe von von sehr
kritischen äußerungen wir sehen ja jetzt
auch diese protokolle erklärung aus
baden württemberg und sachsen gesagt ja
leute das reicht uns nicht das ist
einfach nicht genug um in der jetzigen
situation die pandemie zu bekämpfen das
hätte man eskalieren können man hätte da
im grunde jetzt noch stundenlang sagen
können nein so verabschieden wir das
nicht offensichtlich wollte man wollte
man es nicht so man hat reingeschrieben
diese 29
stellen liebe bundesregierung ihr müsst
uns jetzt für die nächste mpk am 17
januar vorlegen wie ihr weiter verfahren
wollt also da ist ein klarer auftrag für
einen fahrplan und das zweite ist dass
man rein geschrieben hat wir wollen auch
wissen wie es weiter mit der allgemeinen
impfpflicht
jetzt hat bundeskanzler scholz ja vorab
verständnis geäußert für die nöte der
bürgerinnen und bürger in der pandemie
und in den letzten monaten hat ja dieser
gemütszustand wütend die runde gemacht
und mittlerweile hat man ja das gefühl
man braucht eigentlich ein neues wort
dafür weil das nicht mehr ausreicht theo
will die neue bundesregierung jetzt die
bürgerinnen und bürger nochmal
motivieren noch mal mitnehmen in den
kampf gegen diese fünfte welle die sich
aufbaut oder wand von der sogar einige
sprechen
also mein eindruck ist es nun vor allem
auf das impfen setzt also dass man
versucht die vergleichsweise schlechte
impfquote die wir in deutschland haben
dass man die hebt nun wissen wir dass
impfen gegen omikron kein perfekter
schutz ist aber er ist deutlich besser
als ungeimpft zu sein und wenn man
gewusst hat ist also die dritte impfung
hat dann ist man
vergleichsweise sicher also das lka hat
ja heute gesagt wer gepustet ist er hat
ein moderates risiko also ein eher
bescheidenes risiko sich anzustecken
beziehungsweise eben auch eine schwere
erkrankung zu haben also das ist die
hauptstrategie der ampelkoalition der
bundesregierung dass man sagt wir müssen
so viele menschen wie möglich durch
impfen durchpusten schützen und
möglichst milde eingreifen in das
funktionieren der gesellschaft auch in
die wirtschaft in den handel das da ist
natürlich insbesondere die die fdp ein
großer
verteidiger der der wirtschaft und auch
der der freiheit der menschen ich danke
ihnen ganz herzlich für ihre
informationen und ihre einschätzungen
theo koll in berlin entweder noch
ja und er jetzt würden wir die ganze
sache immunologisch gerne nochmal
einschätzen lassen und dazu begrüße ich
professor karsten waschl schon genannt
einen schönen guten abend herr wetzel
sie haben die beschlüsse ebenso gesehen
vielleicht kurze frage vorab wie würden
sie die bewährten wird das ausreichen
omikron in deutschland auszubremsen
ich glaube das kann aktuell niemand
seriös sagen es ist sicherlich ein
erster schritt dass wir jetzt schon
anfangen kontakte zu reduzieren obwohl
ja de facto aktuell die zahlen noch
sinken aber wir sehen einfach das
omikron kommen wird deshalb ist es
erstmal gut dass wir jetzt schon
proaktiv handeln aber man muss ganz klar
sagen wir fahren hier natürlich auf
sicht deshalb ja schon wieder das
nächste treffen im januar um zu
überprüfen ob die maßnahmen denn
wirklich ausreichen
twitter hat eines ragge auf youtube sie
fragt wer setzt denn die zielzahlen fest
müssen alle menschen in deutschland
geimpft werden
ich glaube man muss ganz klar sagen eine
je höher die impfquote desto mehr
menschen leben werden wie retten wir
werden natürlich keine impfquoten 100
prozent erreichen können und
wahrscheinlich auch nicht müssen um aus
dieser panne rauszukommen omikron hat da
sicherlich nochmal die zielmarke nach
oben gesetzt deshalb müssen wir deutlich
über 80 prozent wahrscheinlich auch 90
prozent erreichen ich glaube das kann
man seriös wirklich erst im nachhinein
beurteilen oder wenn man sehr gute
modelle hat gerade auch dann wenn mehr
erfahrung hat wie sich omikron jetzt
wirklich mit den impfungen verhält
gerade in bezug auf die schweren
verläufe
holger hat eine frage auf facebook warum
wurden nicht vor sechs wochen als am
mikro mikron aufkamen alle grenzen
effektiv geschützt warum kam es jetzt
wieder so weit hätte das aus ihrer sicht
hätte es was gebracht
wahrscheinlich nicht weil man ja vor
sechs wochen noch gar nicht abschätzen
konnte wie gefährlich omikron wirklich
wahr da sind die daten erst in den
letzten wochen gekommen und b wir haben
ja in den letzten zwei jahren panini
wirklich gelernt dass das virus sich
sehr schnell weltweit verbreitet und
sich nicht an grenzschließungen hält das
zu dem zeitpunkt als den grenzen
geschlossen worden wären wäre das virus
auch schon in den einzelnen ländern
gewesen und deshalb ist es immer keine
gute strategie sich abzuschotten ich
glaube man kann dem virus setzen nur
begegnen indem man versucht die
ausbreitung im eigenen lande zu
begrenzen mit den kontakt beschränkungen
und natürlich auch mit den impfungen dh
kontakt beschränkungen impfungen welche
maßnahmen werden aus ihrer sicht noch
wichtig
soll man darf eines nicht vergessen wenn
wir jetzt über diesen fehlenden lockdown
reden es gibt ja de facto schon einen
lock down für ungeimpfte sie kommen ja
in restaurants in einige geschäfte in
einigen bundesländern gar nicht mehr
rein weil da die 2g regel gilt was jetzt
neu ist ist dass man auch beschränkungen
für die geimpften ausgesprochen hat weil
man einfach weiß dass mit omikron auch
die geimpften und genesenen wieder am
infektionsgeschehen teilhaben können und
dann einfach die gefahr besteht ist das
virus dann sich deutlich mehr verbreitet
und dann wieder auch die wohl in arabien
gruppen erreicht aber auch die
umkämpften und damit wir wieder mehr
schwere fälle haben und auch mehr
krankenhaus belastungen haben und das
gilt es alles zu verhindern dass
letztendlich
müssen wir versuchen die kugel flach zu
halten also das was wir schon den
letzten kurven gemacht haben damit wir
mehr zeit für die booster impfungen
haben und letztendlich auch dieses
krankenhäuser und kritische
infrastrukturen vor der überlastung
bewahren profil sie haben gerade die
booster impfung angesprochen und da hat
die ständige impfkommission ja heute
empfohlen das jetzt schon nach drei
monaten
auffrischungsimpfungen
stattfinden sollen können sie erklären
was das dann noch mal bringen
es ist einfach so dass natürlich einige
leute weggeschickt worden sind von den
impfzentren weil ihre zweite impfung
noch nicht lange genug her war wenn man
jetzt diesen dreimonatszeitraum einführt
dann können sich wirklich die
allermeisten menschen impfen lassen wir
hatten ende august bereits über 50
millionen menschen die ihre zweite
impfung bekommen haben dh die werden
jetzt alle möglich dass die sich jetzt
schon zwei kämpfen können dh die
entschuldigung tritt eben können dies
jetzt ihre buchstaben punkt holen können
das heißt mit dieser verkürzung und
vorher waren es laut stiko empfehlung
minimal fünf monate erreicht man einfach
dass die booster kampagne viel schneller
fortschreiten kann
kanzler scholz hat ja gesagt das ziel 30
millionen impfungen bis weihnachten wird
erreicht werden bis ende januar sollen
es noch mal 30 millionen sein wie würden
sie das einschätzen wird das dann
ausreichen
zum einen wird dieses ziel mit nochmal
30 sehr schwer zu erreichen sein weil
wir haben aktuell erst 58 millionen
menschen die überhaupt zweimal geimpft
sind das heißt da würden uns noch zwei
millionen menschen fehlen die noch gar
nicht geimpft sind die kann man noch
nicht postern aber natürlich ist das
eine ganz klare ansage dass jeder der
die zweite impfung bekommen hat auch
eine dritte impfung und damit den
booster bekommen soll damit hat man
einen viel besseren schutz gegen omikron
man hat auch wieder einen gewissen
schutz vor der ansteckung rund 75
prozent was aber noch viel wichtiger ist
man hat auch wieder einen viel besseren
schutz vor der schweren erkrankung und
das gilt es zu verhindern
das heißt wenn wir dann einen großteil
der bevölkerung und gerade die
wohlhabenden personen mit der booster
impfung geschützt haben dann können wir
auch verhindern dass omikron zu einer
belastung des gesundheitssystems führt
florian ahler fragt auf youtube wenn die
omikron impfstoffe erst im sommer zu
erwarten sind und die ansteckungsgefahr
so hoch eingeschätzt wird was ist dann
bis zum sommer also ihre antwort wäre im
prinzip mustern und dann mit den neuen
impfstoffen weiter booster
wir haben aktuell nur die impfstoffe zur
verfügung die gegen das original virus
gemacht worden sind wir wissen sie
funktionieren gegen omikron nicht so gut
wie sie gegen delta funktioniert hätten
aber sie sind nicht nutzlos und von
daher ist es jetzt wichtig dass wir auch
die leute mit den jetzt bestehenden und
zur verfügung stehenden impfstoffen
schützen wir werden omikron angepasste
impfstoffe frühestens erst im märz
nächsten jahres haben und dann muss man
wirklich mal sehen ob man dann noch eine
große booster kampagne mit omikron im
stoff braucht oder ob wir dann auch
schon so weit sind dass wir sagen können
die mikrowelle haben wir auch so im
griff man muss aber ganz klar sagen
irgendwann werden sich auch leute die
sich jetzt buchstaben lassen ihre
immunität noch mal auffrischen müssen
das heißt eine auffrischung mit einem
omikron impfstoff wird sicherlich für
die variablen gruppen spätestens im ende
sommer anfang herbst nächsten jahres
wieder stattfinden müssen und wir haben
noch eine e-mail reinbekommen mit der
frage ab wann ist eine musterung nach
zweifacher impfung und überstandener
corona infektion möglich
in dem fall hat die infektion schon für
einen booster des immunsystems gesorgt
und wir wissen auch aktuell dass diese
kombination aus impfung und infektion
sogar den besten impfschutz oder den
besten immunität gibt von daher kann man
diese infektion wenn sie nach der
zweiten impfung stattgefunden hat auch
als booster impfung sehen das heißt man
hat dann sicherlich für die nächsten
sechs monate erstmal ruhe und muss sich
da jetzt über die immunität im moment
noch keine großen sorgen machen
vielleicht wenn wir sie da haben als in
monologen können wir noch mal nach dem
neuen impfstoff fragen nach nowaks den
hat der da die immer er gestern die
zulassung dieses impfstoffs empfohlen
und auf den warten ja einige menschen
die bisher noch gezögert haben mit der
impfung vielleicht kann sie da die
unterschiede noch mal kurz darlegen
bei den bisherigen impfstoffen war es ja
so dass man den bauplan des proteins in
den impfstoffen drin hatte das heißt
dass bei proteinen mussten unsere zellen
selber herstellen bei dem impfstoff von
nowaks ist es jetzt so dass das protein
im labor hergestellt wurde dann in den
impfstoff verpackt wurde und dass dann
verimpft wird was danach im immunsystem
passiert ist genau das gleiche der
körper erkennt dass bei protein als
fremd reagiert darauf macht antikörper
und macht t zell antworten und damit ist
man auch nach einer impfung mit nova
wachs vergleichsweise gut geschützt sei
nowaks hat in den klinischen studien
eine effektivität von rund 90 prozent
gezeigt das kommt also sehr nahe an die
effektivität der mrn impfstoffe run ist
sogar effektiver als die vector
impfstoffe und ist deshalb auch eine
sehr gute alternative also bei den
fraktionen wissen wir dass er sogar noch
einen ticken besser vertragen wird als
die mrm stoffe also diese
grippeähnlichen symptome ein zwei tage
nach der impfung treten auch bei nova
wachs auf auch ein bisschen mehr nach
der zweiten impfung als nach der ersten
impfung aber es ist halt ein guter
impfstoff und wenn der dazu führt dass
sich leute impfen lassen die noch gar
nicht geimpft sind dann kann es nur gut
für die leute seien und auch für uns als
gesellschaft weil je mehr leute wir
geschützt haben desto besser und er
kommen wir auch aus dieser pandemie
wieder raus und können sie sagen wann
dieser impfstoff dann in deutschland
verfügbar sein wird
nach der zulassung ist es jetzt so dass
die lieferung früh nächsten jahres
stattfinden soll und dann wird er auch
sehr schnell verteilt werden also ich
würde davon ausgehen dass man in den
ersten wochen im januar dann auch mit
impfungen dann anfangen kann
dann haben wir noch eine frage von nico
wieder auf youtube ist es schon
untersucht worden inwieweit ein langzeit
schutz gegen korona durch t zellen schon
in der bevölkerung aufgebaut wurde ist
das ähnlich hoch wie die impfquote
ich gehe mal davon aus hier wird gemeint
durch die infektion
natürlich wird man ihn nun durch die
infektion man wird auch immun durch die
impfung was beides macht ist dass die
t-zellen einen lang anhaltenden schutz
vermitteln weil das halt
gedächtniszellen sind die teilweise sehr
langlebig sein können es gibt versuche
die gezeigt haben dass leute auch ein
jahr nach der zweiten impfung immer noch
vergleichsweise gut vor einem schweren
verlauf geschützt sind wie lange das
letztendlich hält kann man noch nicht
seriös sagen weil es die impfung ersten
jahr gibt und die infektion zwar noch
ein bisschen länger aber viele leute die
halt schon infiziert waren haben sich
auch mittlerweile geimpft aber man kann
sicherlich davon ausgehen dass dieser
schutz mehrere jahre halten wird aber
auch gegen omikron wetter natürlich
etwas leiden und irgendwann wird man ihn
auch auffrischen müssen vielleicht noch
eine letzte frage zu den impfungen für
kinder ab fünf jahren die ja seit
vergangener woche möglich sind da gibt
es ja nach wie vor viele eltern die noch
zögern auch weil sie ja bis jetzt keine
allgemeine empfehlungen der ständigen
impfkommission gibt was würden sie sagen
warum ist das so wäre es nicht so dass
omikron da etwas an der empfehlung
ändern müsste
was die stiko ja macht um ihre
empfehlung auszusprechen sie guckt auf
den individuellen nutzen für den
einzelnen geimpften und um den nutzen
der impfung da abzuschätzen muss man zum
einen berücksichtigen wie hoch ist das
risiko der infektion und das andere ist
muss abschätzen können wie hoch ist das
risiko der impfung
weil auch die impfung hat natürlich
nebenwirkungen und da ist es so dass wir
das risiko der infektion bei den kindern
abschätzen können das ist relativ gering
aber sicherlich nicht 0 auch kinder auch
gesunde kinder können schwer erkranken
es ist zum glück die große ausnahme und
bei den impfungen wissen wir
mittlerweile dass sie auch sehr gut
vertragen werden die myokarditis fälle
scheinen als nebenwirkung nochmal
deutlich geringer zu sein bei den
jüngeren kindern als bei den zwölf- bis
16-jährigen und sicherlich kann auch mit
einfließen denn wir lernen dass omikron
für die kinder vielleicht noch
gefährlicher werden und das kann dann
natürlich dazu führen dass die stiko
auch bald ihre empfehlung ergänzt dass
sie sagt wir wissen jetzt die infektion
ist gefährlich geworden und deshalb ist
auch der nutzen der impfung noch mal
höher um dann eine allgemeine
impfempfehlung auszusprechen und der
beschluss war ja auch heute dass die
impfkampagne über weihnachten und
zwischen den jahren und silvester
weiterlaufen soll vielen dank professor
weizel für die einschätzung dieser
maßnahmen und die informationen zu den
impfungen ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend keys danke ihnen auch ja
und auch an sie vielen dank für ihre
fragen und ihre kommentare und das
schlusswort kommt heute nicht von mir
sondern von reinhard retzer der schreibt
nämlich auf facebook ein großer dank an
alle mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
impf und testzentren muss man auch mal
sagen in diesem sinne ein schöner abend
bis bald